welcome everyone to the data science
hangout
and of course welcome back to all
familiar faces and anybody that's
joining for the first time
um just kind of let you know how these
go
there's really no agenda at all it's
basically just a place for data science
leaders and aspiring data science
leaders to connect
and ask questions to one another so you
can put questions in the chat
or just jump in and ask live
we also have a slido link for any
anonymous questions you want to ask too
and rob can help me by putting that in
the chat window if you don't mind
but i'm joined by my co-host for today
sandy steiger director of integrated
analytics
pet at the jm smucker company
and sandy is passionate about community
building and driving data and analytics
usage across the organization so really
excited to talk to you today sandy
and we'd love to have you introduce
yourself then maybe share a bit about
your team and the work that you do
absolutely
uh that was my first thing here so my
name is sandy steiger i am the director
of integrated analytics at smoker this
is a new team actually that they're
building so i'm gonna
it's kind of helpful i think to get a
history of why i landed where i'm at so
i'm gonna kind of talk through that a
little bit for you that'd be great i
a lot of things in my life i feel like
happened because i took a chance and
someone suggested i do something and i
was like you know what yeah i'm going to
try that i think i'm going to try that
so i had a math and business degree when
i was an undergrad and when i was
graduating i was like you know what i
don't really know what i want to do my
personality is kind of big
what type of work can i do with math
that's going to like allow me to be me
and my professor was like i think you
should go on to learn more and i said
i'll try that so i went on to graduate
school
and i was going to go i was going into
um applied mathematics
and a
friend of some of my mom was sitting
next to a graduation went to the same uh
graduate school i did miami university
and said she should do statistics there
aren't many females there and i said
okay i'm gonna try that
and so i did
uh and i earned my master's in
statistics in 2004
and then i went on to
uh i was really fortunate because dun
humvee usa had just come
to the u.s well i guess they were done
humvee started their joint venture with
kroger they came to the us
and i met them and i was like that fits
my personality
they're analytics consultants that's
what i felt like they were which i
didn't want to be in a back room i
wanted to be out there
meeting people understanding their
business problems and then figuring out
how can i use
well at the time i was thinking
statistics and to solve those problems
and frankly i tell people now when i'm
interviewing and hiring that
was so excited when i left school to
apply every model i had learned this was
gonna be so much fun
and then i didn't do that um you do
right but not right away and not most of
the time because the thing that's most
important is keep it simple
and i learned that diagnostic and
descriptive analytics was actually how
we needed to start and especially with
organizations when they're in infancy
with respects to utilizing data and back
then kroger absolutely was there
uh
so then i spent a lot of time
on the keyboard i was the
i know it's super hard to believe but i
was that nerd who got super got excited
when i got a program to run and i got
output and i knew how to analyze it like
you know you have an error in your code
and why is this happening so i cheer
when things would run and process and
one day i was asked if i'd like to take
my hands off the keyboard and that was
like the i just couldn't even believe
someone asked that question why would i
ever want to take my hands off of the
keyboard so i said no probably not fully
and i was kind of half people leader
people manager and then half still doer
of the work
and scoper of all the work
and then lo and behold time went on and
i found myself as the
head of data science for 84.51 now
clearly that didn't happen overnight i
purposely made strategic decisions
within my career to get to that point
um
but i had a lot of fun with it it was
all about
a lot of team development talent
development retention strategies also
setting the strategic vision but the one
thing that i would say that i was the
most passionate about at 8451 was
remembering that our team was made up of
people
and people leadership community building
was what kept people there that's when
we didn't lose as many analysts we
didn't have a
matrician problem
when we met people where they were at
and when we listened to them
so that's what i spent a majority of my
time doing i was the one who
put together all of the team activities
um
and what i'd find was in meetings and
when we'd have big broad share out so
when 8451 was going through the
transformation from
sas to cloud and to open source
programming i remember sitting in the
room and we had all of these brilliant
engineers up talking to the team and
they had what looked like to me outer
space on the screen
in a whole bunch of languages that
didn't make any sense and there was like
little dots moving around on the screen
and i started to look around me and
everybody who also was brilliant data
scientists and i saw fear and i saw
worry and i saw a concern
so i just hopped up
and i started talking to the team and i
started talking to them about
you know
this is end state and yes i have no idea
what's up on this screen either we're
going to figure that out together we're
going to take this slow we're going to
take that step back and what happened
after that meeting was people came up to
me and they said thank you for figuring
out what was going thank you for seeing
us thank you for reading us and it was
in those moments and not just that one
many others while i was there that i
realized the thing that these brilliant
people needed
was a data science
people leader
they needed that person who would be
their voice who could tell the business
what they needed
who could um
just provide them with the support
uh that they needed and they wanted when
they needed it and when they wanted it
when i actually made the decision to
leave 8451
i had some of the
data science experts in the business
come up to me
very concerned that i was leaving and i
said i don't know why you all are so
worried about me leaving i can't teach
you anything you know the world of data
science and what they said to me it
wasn't the it's not what you can teach
us sandy it's what you can do and how
you can lead us and that's the thing
that's missing that's the thing that um
not many and not everybody brings to the
table um
so so anyway i realize i've kind of gone
off on a t maybe not a tangent this is
what i'm passionate about no i i enjoy
that okay good fun
and so anyway so then i went to miami
university and i was leaving their
center for analytics and data science
for two years i enjoyed it i took that
time away full transparency i had had my
fourth baby and i realized i don't have
the time with her that i like and so i
had this great opportunity to build up
this center which was very much focused
on
driving data and quantitative literacy
to across
different groups of thinkers so every
field every industry of study
needs to know data and understand data
and how do i make decisions off of it so
it brought me back to that plus it
brought me back to talent development
closer to this group of people these
young people who are going to be leaving
university so i tried to think through
was what were we teaching at 8451 to
upskill people to get them ready
uh to be analysts or data scientists
with an organization how do i bring that
to a college campus prior to these
students leaving
um
and then i met this guy named doug
jenkins at uh smucker and he was asking
me to help find some junior talent
at the university and i did and he
explained to me this team that he was
building uh it was a new concept well
analytics wasn't a new concept for
smuckers but
the idea of having people
really focused on driving
the usage of data and analytics across
their sales organization it just wasn't
at the caliber they wanted it to be and
they were looking for the right skill
set the right
thinkers to bring into the room and
bring to the table to help drive these
initiatives forward
and i had told him about um some work
that i had done at 8451 and and also
around talent profiles that we had built
which i'm also super passionate about if
anyone is interested in that uh and
they were so this whole new this concept
of team building um i was always told at
miami that i should uh come up with my
own consulting company because that's
what everyone does and
i don't know what the heck i would even
do the one thing i thought maybe i would
do is
consult on
creating and developing highly effective
analytic teams holy moly here's what
they were delivering right to me at
smucker perfect opportunity so i raised
my hand and said hi i might be
interested and that's where i've been
for the last three months
that might have been a lot um i'm not
sure but uh what questions yeah i know i
feel like there's so many great parts in
that and i i love the human-centric
approach that a lot of these talks seem
to to focus around
and just like that fact about like your
role being about the people and
being able to help them communicate
their work how would you
recommend that some of us start to do
that like as we think about moving into
leadership roles
um
i'm trying to think back
to
um
the first thing i did so i went to a
a leadership
training i guess you could call it and
if if i'm being honest i'm not sure that
i
you usually take one or two good things
out of some of those types of sessions
right it's not like a whole full day of
course you're gonna get everything as is
as impactful as you'd like it to be
but this was i think the turning point
for me when i was as a people leader was
they asked the question of does your
team know what uh you expect of them and
everyone in the room said yes our team
has objectives for the year and this
facilitator said i'm not talking about
their objectives on a day-to-day basis
do they know what you as their leader
expect of them
and what they need to do in order to be
successful within your team within your
organization that actually took me back
i was taken aback by that question
because i thought to myself i don't know
how long i was into my career and i
realized i'm not sure anyone had ever
had that conversation with me i don't
know that any manager i'd ever had any
leader had ever sat me down and said
here's what i expect of the people on my
team here's what i want from you on a
day-to-day basis so i sat down and i put
that list i started to think through
that what what does that mean
so i i was thinking about all of the
different people that i admired that i
felt like an inspiration to me and that
i would look out for as those are the
types of people in their careers that i
want to be like at some point in time
and what was what were the
characteristics about them why did i
think they were so successful so i
jotted down a list and then i started to
build that whole list out and i've been
ever since then even to this day so at
least 10 years now i've been sharing
this list with everyone that i work with
i share it in interviews
and i actually wrote a blog post about
it for miami so i'll potentially put
that in the chat in case anyone's
interested in seeing that yeah that
would be great
but those areas and it's kind of cheesy
i i know uh a bit but the first thing i
said was i expect everyone on this team
to be
passionately curious and the only reason
i say that's not super cheesy to say is
because albert einstein said it
and he's you know brilliant so of course
that would be something the reason it's
cheesy because at the time done humvee's
two two of their values was curiosity
and passion and i thought well this is
this is super cheesy that i've combined
them but what did i i started i start to
tell stories about each of these areas
and i bring it to life and i remember
there was a woman who used to work for
me
it didn't mention or it didn't matter to
her what project i gave her
everything excited her because she saw
it as an opportunity to learn something
whether that meant she was learning
about a new category a new product
uh she was learning about a new part of
the business or it was how to work with
a difficult team how to work with a
difficult personality somebody who was
very different than me in their
operating style she just took it all
head on and so from a passion
perspective that's what i wanted to see
and then curiosity around i just want to
know more and i want to dig deeper but
also recognize when i've gone far enough
right because there's always still creep
that you need to be um
watching out for
so that was the first thing um that i
would tell people that's what i'm
looking for you're not gonna love your
job every day right and so as a leader i
would talk about those days with my team
um and i would tell them about days that
i wasn't as having the best day or this
project wasn't the most exciting thing
that i got to work on but i was going to
do it because it was right for the
business so i made sure that they saw
that the both sides for me as well the
stuff i loved and the stuff i didn't
care for as much because they needed to
know that was okay to feel as well
another thing i would say to the team is
um i have really high expectations of
people i expect you to do a lot
um
and you're probably not going to like me
all the time because i'm going to push
you pretty darn hard
uh but i promise you at the end of our
relationship together you will be in a
far different place than you were when
we started uh because i'm going to get
to know you i'm going to understand your
strengths i want to know your boundaries
where's your breaking point not because
i want to break you because i want to
get us to that point and then we'll back
up and then we're going to push against
that breaking point a little bit later
and you'll see that you've grown and
that you can take on more and there's
that more might be more projects or even
just less projects but more technical
but that's the boundaries we want to
push against but i said i need you to be
honest with me when we've gotten to a
breaking point or when you can't take
more
uh a one woman who worked for me one day
she just broke down i said what the heck
is happening right now and she said i
just i can't get all of this work done
and i said how long have you felt this
way i don't know about three weeks and i
said well for three weeks i've been
asking you to keep doing more and you
kept saying yes
let's stop let's look through your
calendar let's start figuring out what
we can push back and what can we not
what can't we do
or what should we say no to
um and then another aspect of honesty is
hey when something breaks when
something's going wrong i need to know
about it i will be
your biggest advocate i will take the
fall i will take the blame for
everything
but i need to know you're fixing it and
i need to know about it i don't want to
be surprised i don't want to find out in
a meeting that i'm in um so like they
also saw that i was there to have their
back and i played that out several times
in meetings i'll be bad guy you'd be
good guy um and so they could see that
in action too to know that i actually
meant it
another thing i would say is i expect
you to be challenging one another we can
do that respectfully so we should be
respectful i always hated that i had to
say that i've never feel like i should
have to tell someone that they have to
respect everyone on the team but you do
uh but from a challenging perspective
i'd say you should be questioning the
data if something doesn't look right if
it doesn't make sense to you ask a
question about it
um is there
do you think that there was a potential
different way to solve the problem
mention it bring it up someone doesn't
have to take your advice or take your
suggestion but it's it's good for us to
be thinking differently and challenging
the thinking of one another so
i said it's our job to always be
challenging ourselves challenging one
another and i even said please challenge
me
i'm not right all the time even though i
jokingly tell you that i am
i know that i'm going to make mistakes i
make mistakes every single day
um and i'll assess up to it i'll tell
you when i've made a mistake but i want
to know like i need you guys to like we
need to be pushing and challenging one
another that's what we're here for
how do you actually like get people to
do that i find that difficult myself
too like how do we
teach people how to have those
conversations especially if we're all
working remotely as well
so what i found is i have to meet people
where they're at in this new role that
i'm in i don't want to
i'm in a unique interesting position
where i'm finding
um
i'm asking questions that have never
been asked before
and so for for what i'm
i'm being asked to deliver things that i
don't think i should be delivering
they're too rudimentary we need to be
elevating we need to be escalating the
work that we're delivering so what i'm
doing is meeting people where they're at
i'm going to deliver part of what you've
asked me for
and then i'm going to say here's what i
think you really need i'm not add to it
right and so i start i started out with
the team of saying let's deliver
what's asked
and more
there are times where i say oh no we're
not going to deliver that that's not the
right way to solve this problem at all
let's sit down and have that
conversation
um yes exactly it's the yes and right um
that's the type of conversations that
we're having what you find and what you
run into is um
there's the
ego um it's not even ego it's more of
the
um
i
i'm so
this is my work and are you trying to
tell me my work is bad if you're
challenging it and so i'm trying to
coach my team to to suggest as well that
always start with these are some really
good insights have we ever thought about
looking at the data or digging into this
a little bit further i remember there
was a woman on my team
and i tried she was developing herself
in her career she was moving into more
of a senior analyst type of position and
i would she'd ask me to come sit in and
observe meetings but not necessarily to
play an active role
and i
so was listening she was offering up
suggestions on how to solve the problem
and i thought that's not
i don't know that's the 100 accurate way
to do it so i followed up but in the
conversation with i think that's a
really great place to start in solving
this problem i'd add on to this plan by
adding these questions this approach um
so it wasn't a oh god no that's the most
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
um i'm i'm more talking about let's
you know yes i really think that's a
great approach um or and let's build
from here yeah
thank you i'm starting to see a few
questions that are coming in that window
so i want to make sure i ask some of
those too
ian i see you you asked a question
around the talent profiles do you want
to ask that live or introduce yourself
sure i don't mind um hey sandy my name
is ian hunter i'm data science manager
for quorum health um in nashville and
you mentioned and got really excited
about talent profiles
um and so i was wondering if you could
elaborate on
um what are these talent profiles that
you're excited about are they based on
data science skill level for hiring or
upskill profiling just kind of elaborate
on that for me
so i'm gonna tell you one thing too and
what people say about me is wow you get
very excited about this
so um that's one thing that i'm not
lacking of is excitement and passion
around anything in this space um so here
let me explain a little bit about where
the talent profiles came from and why we
took the time to develop them
as you're probably aware of being in
analytics roles and analytics leadership
or data science uh
we
we were getting a lot of questions from
the team around so i have my
expectations that actually weren't
technically related at all but the team
would say i don't understand what i need
to do to advance in the in the team how
do i get promoted it always comes back
to how do i get promoted um what skill
sets do i need to develop
and so what we did as a group the whole
leadership team i brought us all
together and i said we need to start
writing down
what are all of the skills that our
teams require like what are the needs
right what is it that we expect of
everybody so we actually
i think we had a list of probably 50 or
60 things now what does that look like
uh communication skills business acumen
so some of the business the more general
stuff that you need to know just by
being in the workforce right
then we had uh things around
storytelling so data storytelling data
visualization
more technical skill sets around coding
in r or python
sas as well was on our list there's
nothing wrong with sas i'm a sas gal
um and there was
more engineering type of a skill set as
well around the automation so we had
blown out this list of about
50 or 60 skills i think we dwindled that
list down once we started to look notice
some overlaps then what we did was we
defined what each of those skills meant
and gave a description of what it meant
to be a beginner intermediate and
experienced within that skill
for each one of our grade levels within
the organization from entry level all
the way up to a senior manager on the
team
how advanced did we expect you to be
were you a beginner intermediate or
advanced or an expert and you would
notice that some of those skills would
change right so like as a beginner on
the team or sorry as a more junior entry
level on the team i probably do need to
have more of the technical skill set be
a more avid efficient coder but as you
evolve up into more senior people leader
type of positions like i i love that
skill set could do you know diminish a
little bit for me
not everyone that was just how my role
actually played out
then what we did was got real nerdy and
we clustered all of those skills and we
found that there were four main buckets
or segments that actually started to
emerge and we used those to profile our
team and we came up with what we were
called our
data science dna is what we call that
so everyone on the team would rate
themselves against each of the skills
and you would start to see
you could see how where you were right
from i think we did like a one to five
scale or something like that
and then you would find out what type of
analysts am i so we had the just general
bucket of skills but then the three
segments that really started to
um
define our group we have what was called
an insights bucket and this would be the
analytic translator that person who
understands the technical aspects of the
role but is that great communicator out
to the business so i understand the
business problem i know the right
approach to solving it i'm not
necessarily the one who's actively doing
it perhaps products or capabilities have
been built i run my analysis pull the
insights and the story together with the
recommendations and i deliver that back
out to the business
we also then had a
more of the machine learning statistical
theorists as we were we would call them
they were the people in the background
thinking about the automated machine
learning so they're building the
products and capabilities
implementing more of the sophisticated
analytics predictive prescriptive when
you think about that analytics curve
that those of us who are more insights
analysts could utilize in our day-to-day
work and deliver that out to the
business now i'm in no way shape or ma
i'm not at all saying that those people
who were
the machine learning or the statistical
theorists weren't actively engaging with
a client they were
uh but their skill set was utilized a
bit differently um and we would
collaborate on projects and then our
third bucket
was our technologist is what we called
it but that role
it felt very engineering but they were
the ones who would think about our
products and our capabilities and how do
we make them
so how do we automate those so that we
basically take that you know that
repetitiveness out of our positions and
actually just feed it into a system that
can run for us very quickly
and spit out those insights um
i started to do research after we had
developed these as well and found that
other organizations were thinking about
their people in a similar way they had
different buckets but it really made us
feel like oh wow look at this we are on
to something here and our people loved
it too because
they could see where did they fall out
with their skills and if they were like
me an insights analyst but wanted to
push the boundaries into the statistical
theorist they now knew the very specific
skill set they should go in and focus on
learning and and could find that mentor
that was another really cool thing we
did out of this tool is when you rated
yourself if you could say it like i want
to be
i want to get more experience with or i
want to develop in
automated machine learning
the system would send out to you okay
well here are some people who along with
their manager rate them as some experts
within the team these might be good
mentors for you to reach out to so that
was a fun thing that we did as well um
utilizing our thing
can you
chat a bit or just speak a bit more
about that tool
that sounds good um so sure but i didn't
build it and i was more of a user of it
uh but they really just built in our
shiny app that we could use so all of
the data was implemented
so you i think for them i think don't
quote me on this originally we started
it in excel
so everyone would rate themselves send
it off to the person who would upload it
and upload the data into r shiny and
then or r they would run it through the
r shiny app and then it would spit out
um the information but i think by the
time i left they had
made it a bit more sophisticated where
it all just happened within that app
versus having to do it in excel send it
off somebody load it
yeah
wow that's cool
um
is that
so are you starting to maybe
take some of
what you did at a prior role and apply
it to this new role how are you building
a community now and like mentorship
programs
that's exactly what i'm hoping to do
but i've only been here for three months
so again i'm trying to meet people where
they're at and i'm not trying to
overwhelm anyone with i with my ideas i
recognize that i am
the new gal on the team and i want to
make sure that i am providing what the
team needs so that's the first thing i'm
doing is actually listening to the new
analyst that we're hiring there are so
we've just hired in the last three
months 25 people
that's overwhelming and i am one of
those 25 so i'm on boarding
people who are new and as i'm onboarding
so it's a it's a tricky situation
but the first thing i noticed was that
we weren't coming together as a group
and
yes we're virtual and i understand that
so it's very hard to come together as a
group but this is coming together as a
group so i created what we're calling
analytics learning labs
i know like we're all 25 of us are
learning something new right now we're
all upskilling in this business there
are some people within the team like
15-ish that were already here um but
what i've heard from them too is there
are still parts of the business i don't
know enough about so i've created these
analytic learning labs
and
we come together on a weekly basis to
learn something new about so part of the
onboarding plan but also an introduction
to different parts of the business than
perhaps we weren't necessarily in
uh
or been exposed to in the past
my ideal
my idea though moving forward is once we
get some of this learning stuff out of
the way learning about the business out
of the way we're gonna learn about the
work everyone is doing so it's showcases
that that the team can do uh talk about
their work
um i need some peer review on this
approach that i'm applying to this
problem can you all help me figure out
is up the right model is it the right
output is the right interpretation is
this a good story to be telling
so i want to give that people the
opportunity to
um get exposure that way because we're
continuing to be in this remote world
it's very hard to then meet people
across the team so um but yes i am and
then i also had some people on the team
reach out to me and ask
we need
uh this is something that's been missing
with from the organization as
women in leadership
how do we can we talk to some of these
younger women within the organization
and talk to them about how to become
women a female leader in analytics how
did you get there how did you make some
of the career choices you made
sacrifices that you had to make along
the way
and kind of sort of mentor and build
each other up that way
i love this community building piece i'd
say this is probably my favorite topic
to talk about and i i know on a prior
call someone had brought up um like how
do we actually get people to want to
share their work or if someone thinks
maybe it's too like
entry level of an example how do you
foster that community and the sharing
so i did this thing in 84 51 which is
going to sound very similar to analytics
learning lab
but i called it peer review uh i got
asked there uh sandy i just don't know
how to think on my feet in a meeting
how do you know when you're in a
conversation and someone asks a question
how do you not stutter how did you just
talk and answer the question well part
of that is experience right you've just
been around the block a time or two and
you figure that out
and
fake it till you make it sometimes i
hate that i hate that saying and i hate
saying that but sometimes that's a bit
of where you have to be
but also
practice
let's get up and pressure test you in
front of a crowd so we actually made a
rule that any project that was delivered
had to go through peer review
everything had to be shared with the
project with a group of analysts
and when you presented in this peer
review session
you
you had to let the audience know what
role you wanted them to play am i
pretending as if i'm the client
receiving this so you're doing a very
formal presentation to me
or are you treating me as an analyst and
you want me to help you better assess
whether the technique pressure test that
pressure test how you've done that the
data you use the model you've built and
then that output interpretation
um or is this more of a i just want to
do a project share out and make sure
you're all aware of what i'm building
because i think it's going to be
beneficial to the rest of this team down
the line and so looking for feedback in
that way too
so we kind of started to go down that
path where a majority of the work
actually did have to be presented in
that way because it
i don't like that word force but like it
encourages the practice before the
before the formal presentation yeah
thank you i see there's a few anonymous
questions coming in from slido so just
want to let everyone else know if you're
joining in a little bit later that you
can ask anonymous questions there and
someone asked what makes someone a great
analytics mentor
uh
i so like
all right i'm gonna say this and
i don't like to talk myself up ever
right because i think that i actually
have a lot to learn and i don't know
so when rob and rachel reached out to me
to do this i was like do you really
think i'm the right person to do this
i'm just not sure about that and they
can attest that i actually said that
okay
but what i found is
i've only been at smoker for three
months and i have had three separate
people reach out to me and say hey could
we chat i'd like to learn more i'd like
to pick your brain about how to do this
how to be in this field how to continue
to grow myself and how to stretch myself
and so um a lot of what i do again it's
just honestly i don't push my way into a
conversation i just look for somebody
what do you need from me i'm happy to
help you in any way some people i said
if you just need someone to talk to do
you need someone to vent to about a
situation i'm happy to be that person
but you need to also let me know do you
need my advice do you need some do you
need some thoughts on how you might
approach this um so i try not to
overstep bounds in that way um and what
i also have been i try to share with
people too is a lot of times what's
needed is they want a coach right they
want something to just provide them with
a few plays a few drills something to
give them a kickstart um here's how you
might want to start this here's the
right approach for taking this or
heck yes i decided that i needed to take
a step back in my career because it
wasn't working for my family
are there parts of me and some days
where i'm like god i hate that i felt
like i had to do that because i couldn't
get the space i needed at my job yeah
but um but it worked for me in the end
right so like i'm i'm willing to give
people like i just i share my stories i
share the successes the failures i had i
noticed that there are a lot of um
of men on this call as well and i'm not
saying this to dis any of you because i
think you're all very delightful and i
love working with men but i've been the
only since i started my career a lot of
times i was the only woman in the room
and i said take up your space it took me
so long to learn that but like i've
tried to build in this confidence with
people now also i'm making it sound like
i can only or it's like this only
females need the support
um
i am an honest
transparent person so i've had many many
men on my team as well look for to me
for mentorship and support and guidance
um
and frankly i've just told them how it
is they've asked me why don't people
want to work with me and
like well you come across as the
know-it-all in the room so perhaps we
need to change that attitude so like i
think that's helpful in a mentor as well
somebody who's willing to tell you what
maybe you don't want to hear sometimes
i'm sure that's also helpful in
communicating with the business too
like the way that you're
maybe phrasing certain things and
um
i didn't want to jump to a different
topic too too soon but was curious like
what other
recommendations would you have taking
what you just said there about
communicating with the business as well
um
so i just sent a note out yesterday to
somebody within the business and i was
giving them my recommendation for how we
should approach a meeting that's coming
up
and i said
i would not go into this customer
meeting
and talk about us as a company
don't
go into that meeting talking about them
and what they need to be successful what
where their current wins are
their successes where are they lagging
and then ideas that we have around how
they could potentially win in those
lagging areas
but don't focus it on us and our brains
and that's controversial right because
most cbg companies we want to go in and
talk about well here's how we can help
or here's what we can do and i said i
think we'll get invited to a second
conversation if we focus on them and i
had
two
two camps right there was one camp of
well no we need to make sure that they
know that here here are here are the
things we're bringing to the table and
then i had the vps on the room saying no
that's this is what we need to be doing
right we want to be strategic partners
and a strategic partner would talk about
the customer the strategic partner
doesn't say
what about me here's what i here's what
i'm looking for and here's what we need
out of this partnership so
we'll get there eventually um but i'm
also like
as a new person too it's easy and even
when i wasn't the newbie in the room um
i would ask some of the more difficult
questions around why are we looking at
it this way and could i potentially take
a stab at looking at it a different way
or potentially approaching the problem
um
shaping
deliverables in a different way so that
they tell a more cohesive story and that
they live on their own
i like that thank you i see um christian
that you had asked a question earlier
that was kind of
a bit about our studio products
specifically so i don't want to like use
it as a way to endorse our studio um
like pro products but
christian would you want to kind of
speak to maybe what you're going through
or questions that you have about
leveraging tools to drive growth at the
business
and i can read the question too if you
want
the christian asked are you using our
studio team and if so could you give an
example of a time that your team has
been able to leverage those tools to
drive growth
so
teams is in microsoft teams or
are christians referencing our studio
pro products specifically but i think it
could be in general
so perhaps that answers your question
then christian when i say microsoft
teams
uh
so
um
in my past life
at 84 51 there was the migration to from
sas to open source so r and python
and i was a part of the
i had to get the organization to really
truly invest in this space they kept
saying why aren't we utilizing r more
you guys should be doing this more why
is it taking us so long to move off of
sass or to move off of these other
products
and
my i finally went into the room and i
just shared with them this nirvana state
like here's an example a gold star
project do you guys all love how this
went and how the output and they're like
yes absolutely that's what we should be
doing and i said great we can do one of
these at a time and it takes about three
months to do because we don't have the
right infrastructure in place
and
what do you mean he said you're not
investing
you're not investing in servers you're
not investing in the training of the
team to be able to use these products um
so they're
we we changed the church we were able to
get the resources that we need i know
i'm not answering christian's questions
specifically
um but what i've been what i tried to
tell the team too as we were migrating
was i'm not i don't care so much about
the tool that you use i care that we're
using the right solutions and the right
product we're solving the problem in the
right way so if r is the right solution
if python is the right solution
if say us or
ultrex or tableau or whatever it might
be that's what we should be using if we
have those at our disposal um in my team
today at smucker we're hiring people
with
uh
what wide ranging skills so there are
some people on my team who've actually
not coded before they're very
comfortable running syndicated data
reports
panel reports and then packaging those
up to tell a really great story um and
then there are others on the team who
frankly i would say are more data
science
minded and skill set-wise who are very
comfortable and familiar using
r and other programming languages and
that's what they want to be utilizing in
their day job
so i'm not sure that i have 100 answer
to that question other than we're trying
to use the best resource to solve the
business problems
i i like that and i remember that from
when we first talked with
me and rob just chatting about the data
science hangout and mentioning how you
don't care what tool people use as long
as they're getting the job done and
they're using what is best for them yes
yes
kevin i i see you asked a question
around leadership and i was wondering if
you want to introduce yourself and ask
that live
yeah i would love to um so i'm kevin um
working at grail the statistical analyst
um
so having a great time there hi kevin um
hello um i was wondering you've had so
many
like a very long path and a very like
awesome like leadership path
um had so many different roles i was
wondering which role you found most
rewarded
um
[Music]
so this oh god i'm such a dork um i kind
of get chills whenever i think about
this which again is ridiculous uh people
used to ask me all the time what was
your what's your proudest moment when i
was at 84 51 and actually what i would
tell them was when i was working with
somebody who was struggling and i'd and
i'd see them succeed
i spent time in them i invested in them
i helped them develop their skill set i
got them to the point where people
started to say oh look at what they can
contribute because i saw potential in
people but oftentimes others maybe
either were too busy to see
or weren't willing to see so that's
actually been the most rewarding is just
working with people and seeing them
continue to grow
in their usage of data and analytics
and
um
their
ability to influence the organization
because of those skill sets that i've
helped them to develop and think
differently and ask challenging
questions but um
those were some of my proudest and the
things that i had the most fun with and
enjoyed the most
yeah thank you very much yeah and then
in kind of building on that too from a
leadership perspective
um i feel like a lot of my time and how
i got to those roles
was basically self-taught i mean you
learn from some of your good managers
and you also learn from those who
weren't so great in developing you over
time
um
and i remember there were always there
were many different opportunities for
training or even leadership programs
that the organization was sending people
to and i and i kind of got mad once
because i asked about them and i was
told oh well you're already figuring
this stuff out you're already doing it
we don't necessarily think you need it
and i said you can't stop investing in
me i need it too
so i also would speak up for myself so i
think those were opportunities too where
just because i could figure it out on my
own doesn't mean i should have had to
you think then sorry as a follow-up
question do you think then is it more
important to be
i guess pushed into
um
like i guess leadership and like more
teaching yourself how to do these things
or do you think it's more or should
should industries be
teaching you how to be passionate if
that's even possible
great
interesting question because
i learned
some lessons the hard way it took me a
long time to be comfortable with who i
was what i was good at
um
and just to have the confidence that i
felt i needed i used to like look i
would minimize my space in a room
sometimes because i was just like i'm
not sure i have as much value to add on
this conversation i'd wait for others to
speak up and then i remember one um
training that i was in
was probably the most quiet person in
the room which is surprises people now
to hear this but i i would and i had
answered a couple of questions and the
facilitator was like
you guys need to listen to her when she
speaks she really doesn't which was like
hello that sounds terrible like when she
speaks listen to her but she knows what
she's talking about like she's got
really good ideas and that made me like
it clicked for me in that moment like
stop doing these things be a voice voice
that opinion and in leadership roles i
remember
i i do wish that i had been given
opportunities been assigned a mentor i
never was given i had to find people
myself which actually i prefer to do i
prefer to find people who are in the
same life stage or about to be you know
just past the life stage i'm in so that
i can learn from them
but at the same time i wasn't given
those opportunities to truly
um be coached
on how to lead and i coached on how to
have effective conversations with
leadership i sort of had to fumble
through it i did just fine clearly i got
into a really great position at 84 51
but there were times and i even when i
left i said
you didn't invest as much time in me as
i think you should have yeah i learned
it a lot myself now do i think people
should be pushed into those types of
positions
no
i think that with a question mark uh
because i worked with some very
technical
um
data scientists at 8451 who had said to
me i don't want to be a people manager
if you need someone to tell to be a
technical mentor or a technical manager
i'm all in
but if it's going to come to me having
to
manage them their performance management
stuff just the conversations throughout
the year that's not what i want to do
that's not where i'm passionate and so i
didn't want to ever force someone into a
position like that some people figured
out over time they enjoyed it um
but
does that answer your question
yeah i think so um yeah it is
interesting that yeah some people some
people are like very driven towards
um just being technical and just wanting
to do wanting to stay in the data
analysts um or staying behind the
keyboard as you were saying before
rather than like
dealing with people and doing all of
that argus um task if that's their um
opinion about it um but yeah i think
yeah thank you for answering my question
and i see there's an anonymous question
as well that is related to
this topic um
so do you think that it's possible to to
really do both well like the hands-on
development work and management
like i know you
mentioned at the beginning that at first
you didn't want to be
a leader because you wouldn't get to
actually do that that hands-on coding
i think it depends on the size of a team
so when i was originally put in the
position where i had a i was managing a
team and scoping and doing work i
probably had two or three people
reporting to me when i was the head of
data science i had 15. uh there was
absolutely no way that i was going to be
able to do work uh do technical work
hands-on technical work while managing
that level or that amount of people
um so but i could have my hands in the
different types of projects and offer up
opinions on
perhaps not the right approach or the
specific model to apply or the
analytical technique
but i could offer suggestions around
here are some other questions that you
might want to
attempt to answer with that or here's
another angle a different way of
thinking about it or interpreting some
of those results right so we could
pressure test in that way too
um so i think it's possible up to a
certain level and then once you have hit
a certain point you just can't possibly
manage it all or wait maybe you can i
just didn't figure i couldn't figure out
a way to do that and have
four kids yes i have four kids there's
no way that i was gonna be able to have
the life i wanted there plus the career
that i was aspiring to have and you know
so it's just um
you have to make choices in my opinion
and sometimes those choices aren't the
ones that
you might shift over time so
thank you i think this is a really
important uh question as well that came
in anonymously as i've progressed in my
career i feel guided into people
management roles and they said maybe
because i am a woman whereas i like and
am good at technical work
any advice for this
ask for what you want
ask for what you want um that was the
one thing
when i think back to my younger self is
i didn't speak up on my own behalf
i didn't fight for what i really wanted
sometimes and that was unfair
once i finally felt comfortable with my
own voice and my own skin
um things started to happen in fact like
okay so i was asked to do to speak at
another engagement and i was telling my
husband like you know i don't know
someone so asked me how did you get
involved how did you get asked to do
that they didn't ask it that way like
how did you get asked to do that but i
interpreted that way right and my
husband finally said to me we stopped
we stopped saying that you've earned
everything that you've that you've
gotten right everywhere you've gotten to
you worked really hard to get there you
need to start remembering that and you
have to you have to tell people you want
what you want and ask for those sorts of
things and
in some situations did you mandate um
i i have worked with so many other
people with those personalities male and
female
who never felt
bad right about demanding things and i
was always the one in the room people
like i would really like the opportunity
if you think i should have it if you
don't think i should that's okay thing
too so i'll just sit back here and be
quiet again
i need to break that down i need to stop
doing that so if you feel whoever asks
that question if you feel like you're
the person who's just like okay yes i'll
just do whatever you tell me to do but
i'd rather be doing this thing over here
ask for it
show what you're capable of
in that space
thank
you there was a few questions earlier
that i'm i'm scrolling up trying to keep
track here that i realized i missed and
one goes back to
a few points ago when we were talking
about managing the team and what do you
do when someone is underperforming how
do you handle that
well i've had to deal with that a few
different times in my career
uh and i want to tell you and i don't
know if you've experienced this as well
no matter
the amount of times that you tell
someone that they're not meeting
expectations when you finally sit down
with them to have that conversation
about a performance plan
they are blown away that you are having
that conversation um and no one really
seems to they say no no people should
never be surprised you're correct they
shouldn't be because you've had the
comfort but they always are they always
are surprised um but again i'm i try to
be very
open honest transparent along the way so
as soon as i start to notice a behavior
i call it out hey i've noticed that
you're trending in this direction here
are some things i think we need to do to
stop that or to change some here's how
you're not meeting expectations your
deliverables are late we're not meeting
deadlines what might be happening
um or also not just say like you're not
doing what you're supposed to be doing
saying hey i noticed we we've missed
this deadline was there something going
on that i didn't wasn't aware of because
sometimes it might even just be that
um
a co-worker of mine i didn't know that
she was going through a really hard time
in her marriage and like she told me
that i was like shoot we could have
helped right as a team so there's often
times where you can meet people like
figure things out what's going on behind
the scenes but have the conversations
repeatedly and also come up with a plan
actually i try to put it in their hands
here are the areas that you're not
meeting expectations what do you think
you should do to me to like improve in
those areas and then let's get back
together and talk about those what might
be missing from that plan
and then we'll still um and then we'll
kind of align on it and meet regularly
about it so even when people might be
having a hard time in their personal
life that doesn't mean we can allow them
to continue to not meet expectations it
just gives you a frame of reference for
where they might be at and how can i
potentially approach them in a different
way so
hopefully that's helpful
thank you yeah it seems like
regardless of if we're talking about
like data science leadership questions
or commun or like sharing things out to
the business so much of it comes back to
communication
and i know
um rick who's on the call and i were
kind of chatting on linkedin earlier
this week around
like the skills that you use to succeed
in data science and what you're taught
is not normally the communication
type of skills and rick i'm curious if
you want to weigh in on on that and what
we were chatting about
yeah sure i think i also put a message
in the chat here i mean the more i think
about
what we were taught about communication
goals is they're very poorly defined
because communication skills
encompasses massive massive spectrum of
things that that you need to do and also
communication itself is very poorly
defined and i feel that
technical people
see the world and understand their work
in a certain way and that helps them to
excel in math and sciences and all the
things that we love and do and then
the people skills part and the
communications part as part of that
requires a completely different way to
understand how pieces fit together and
how these things work and one one thing
i've kind of convinced myself about in
trying to understand how to teach
communications and these kind of
so-called soft skills to technical
people is that they need to reframe the
way that they approach these kind of
skills and that it's not this hard
versus soft
kind of thing which already kind of
separates them out right like i'm very
good at the technical hard skills but
these soft fuzzy skills i have no idea
about so i can't i can't bother with it
which already kind of puts them on
another level but to kind of reframe the
way that they approach these things and
see
how they can understand those skills and
their skills in on one spectrum and that
they're kind of operating not as kind of
changing their their mind and saying
well i just have a microsoft skills or
those are people people and i can't do
that i do the tarot technical stuff but
to kind of reframe
all of those skills as kind of a
spectrum and say well my technical
suffering this side and my my people
suffer on this side but it's all kind of
one wide spectrum and i'm moving and
operating on this on the spectrum
instead of saying
it's a dichotomy it's a binary thing
where i need to make this huge leap
in a binary which is boring and hard but
it's a it's a continuous spectrum it's a
three-dimensional multi-dimensional
range of skills that you move around in
and that's a that's the way i kind of
try and approach how i think about
communications and people's skills when
i talk to technical people
you know it's real interesting to hear
you talk about this because i
can't remember who it was within this
last probably six months i was talking
them and they said i get so tired of
people saying soft skills communicating
about data is not a soft skill
that's not easy
um storytelling that's not a soft skill
sure it's not a technical in the sense
of like i'm writing code or engineering
or in that realm of technical but it's
still on the spectrum right and we have
to so i would i created a um
art and science of storytelling training
at miami for the students to go through
so that they could flex that muscle
because that was absolutely something
they needed to be able to do it wasn't
just because i was seeing some of the
stuff they were delivering i'm like you
have really great insights the way
you're delivering it isn't so great
let's talk about that let's develop that
skill yeah
yeah
i would i'm not sure if that's something
that's publicly available but i would
love to see that
if that's something that is available
somewhere yeah sure you know i probably
so i also picked up a class at miami and
i used i taught the the same sort of
content
in my first lecture so i'll have to go
out and see if i can find it a lot of
that stuff is probably still on my miami
computer i didn't take it with me
but yeah but the concepts i still have
rachel so i can share those
that would be great
yeah i think um
people are all commenting plus one and
sure i need to take a class like that
too
yeah um as we get to the top of the hour
here i know some people may have to drop
off and
sandy if you have to drop let me know as
well
but just want to see if people have
follow-up questions for you what's the
best way to get in touch
well
you can get in touch with me over
linkedin if you'd like or you could you
know i can you want me to drop my email
address in the chat in case anybody
wants to chat with me there or would you
prefer to just say
linkedin
whatever's better for you if linkedin we
could put your linkedin uh
url there
yeah i will put my email address to just
in case anybody has any other questions
um
awesome
yep
thank you and if it's okay to ask a few
more remaining questions
i have a few more minutes yep okay cool
thank you there was one other anonymous
question on how do you foster an
environment where teammates challenge
each other
i make sure that everyone remembers that
we are not here
to
poke we are here to make everyone better
we are here to learn from one another um
and i oftentimes will allow myself to be
the first victim of it like here's what
i've put together let's tell me what's
wrong with it tell me what i could do
better let's challenge but but a lot of
it too is just around remember there's
positive intent
we aren't actually here because we want
someone else's job we all really
genuinely want our team to be successful
we want each other to be successful we
want the business to be successful and
that's why we're challenging yeah so i
try to remember and if i ever feel like
um
tensions are rising or tones start to
get different i oftentimes jump in and i
am a i'm a very sarcastic person and i
like i use humor a lot
and so to like break up that tension and
so i'll jump in with whatever it might
be whatever i feel like is needed in
order to break that back down and bring
everyone back to remember that we are
one train one team
we're all here to succeed
definitely and
and rob and robert as you're also
helping monitor the questions please let
me know if i missed anything i was uh
scrolling through some of the
the discussion in the chat as well and
i see some really great points from tori
as well around communication and
like that reminder of
like putting things into terms that
people in the business can understand as
well and trying not
like some understanding that sometimes
it can intimidate people some of the
work
that data scientists do
that's the thing that i've i've been
thinking about a lot lately and this
isn't just about smucker this is
actually about many organizations that i
was exposed to while i was at miami and
then even 8451 and kroger who have been
working in this space for such a very
long time
um i said that
data and numbers are hard for a lot of
people they don't get it when you show
them a number oftentimes they feel
paralyzed and so it is our job to make
sure that they understand like we show
them
in a very clean easy to understand
visual well and through a nice headline
or a nice one pager we just spell it all
out simply we tell them exactly what
they needed to know based on the data
um
and try to actually show
don't put a data table i can't stand
that i don't sometimes i guess it's very
helpful but like most of the time let's
not use data tables um because a lot
like sometimes people just don't even
know where to look like how do i look at
this what am i supposed to do with it
too many numbers i don't know which one
is the most important
like it's it's in
math is and it's not just numbers are so
intimidating for some people
as one final question i'd love to ask
you as we've kind of been bringing this
up on a bunch of the different sessions
as well are there any podcasts or
resources that you'd recommend or things
that you listen to or read
um
i
a lot of what
i'll say from a reading perspective it
comes down to
um they're so well it was a former
colleague of mine but becoming a data
head is a
this is a really good i have it right
next to me and actually i posted about
it with my daughter she's only three so
she didn't really read it but i
pretended
but this book i don't like reading books
like this and i told my co-worker i
don't write like reading books like this
because when i'm not at work i don't
want to be reading about work but i told
him
and i i always feel like they're over my
head and i'm a smart enough person so
like i just it just i don't it doesn't
click for me anymore because i'm not i
feel like because i'm not in school
this was so easy to understand and i
enjoyed it
and i enjoyed it and so i was like well
done alex
you and jordan did a really nice job on
this book here i even wrote a little
something in here for them to like
that was me
i need a book like this
now for like a podcast
oh because i'm i have imposter syndrome
pretty badly there's a good podcast
there i'm gonna have to go back and find
it because it's been a while since i
listened to them but it's really just
about remembering like what you bring to
the table so anything like that and i'm
just more of a
i need inspiration and there's that
inspiration often times i need it not in
the form of inspiring me to want to do
more analytics just inspire me make
bring positivity to my life so that's
just some of the other things that i
like to read
um there's also another book that has
the f word in the title
um you know the subtle art of not giving
an f um that's a good one too because i
often care too much so
i like that not sure if i should say
that because it's being recorded so i
just
that's okay
thank you thank you so much danny i'll
do one last check to see if anyone on
has any other questions that i've missed
can i give a few more
um
sandy just from listening to you it
sounds like you're
very passionate about team building if
they're if you haven't read nine lies
about work it sounds terrible
but it is it is great
it basically talks about what makes a
team
function well and it's really about you
know you're surrounded by people with
similar
um
priorities they've got your back like
it's
i think it would ring true to you um
yeah
i love this stuff adam grant has a
podcast that people also are interested
in
um podcasts he he is a
social scientist i got that right
um basically he studies how to make work
not suck and the people that he
interviews on the podcast are fun so
well check that out
i just told my boss today because or
yesterday i said people need something
to believe in they need someone to
believe in and that's what they're
looking for in like their job right and
it's not even like i'm more i always
worry that like people are going to
leave and it happens right but like for
the most part i just want people to
realize like
enjoy know that they have a manager or a
leader that supports them that believes
in them that listens listens to them
um and so yeah i'll definitely i took
the note i'll check those two things out
but um sounds right up my alley
tori what was the name of the first book
sorry i got to claim it's called nine
lies about work here i'll send a picture
okay
thank you it sounds terrible
i know
but it really is great oh i can't send a
picture i'll send the link to amazon
okay cool thank you so much you got no
problem yeah and the follow up on
torrey's comment i posted this in the uh
comments there's a book called quiet by
susan kane
and it's all about
introverted people and there's a whole
section on
everything that's wrong about open open
format offices and all these studies
that just show
how
collaboration doesn't have to happen
with a group of people in fact
collaboration can happen like this
uh and they they show you that there's a
lot of studies that say collaboration
happen when happens better when people
work on their own they bring it together
and then they go back and work on their
own it's a fact it's been a fascinating
read so far
thanks
and a little preview brian butler will
be speaking with us all next week
thank you so much sandy i really
appreciate your time and and being so
open and honest and candid with us
well thank you for inviting me rachel i
i hope something of value was brought to
everyone on the call so appreciate the
time
thank you have a great rest of the day
everyone